it's not gpt4
that's terrifying it's the gpt4 is a
baby technology
you know at Microsoft even had a paper
recently out
with the title something like sparkles
of AGI whatever basically saying this is
baby AI
like these little Neanderthal babies
and it's gonna grow up there's going to
be other systems from from the same
company from other companies they'll be
way more powerful and but they're going
to take all the things
ideas from these babies
and before we know it we're gonna be
like
those last neanderthals who were pretty
disappointed and when they realized that
they were getting replaced well this
interesting point you make which is the
programming is it's entirely possible
that GPT 4 is already the kind of system
that can
change everything
by writing programs
yeah it's because it's Life 2.0
the systems I'm afraid of are going to
look nothing like a large language model
and they're not
but once it gets once it or other people
figure out a way of using this Tech to
make much better Tech right it's just
constantly replacing its software and
from everything we've seen about how how
these work under the hood they're like
the minimum viable intelligence they do
everything you know the dumbest way that
still works sort of yeah and um
so they were life 3.0 except when they
replace their software it's a lot faster
than when you when when you decide to
learn Swedish
and moreover they think a lot faster
than us too so when uh you know we don't
think uh have
one
logical step every nanosecond or a few
or so the way they do and we can't also
just suddenly scale up our Hardware
massively in the cloud because we're so
limited right
so they are in it they are also life
have
consumed become a little bit more like
life 3.0 and that if they need more
Hardware hey just rent it in the cloud
you know how do you pay for it well with
all the services you provide
yeah
and what we haven't seen yet
which could change a lot is uh entire
Software System so right now programming
is done sort of in bits and pieces uh as
as an assistant tool to humans but I do
a lot of programming and with the kind
of stuff that gbt4 is able to do I mean
it's replacing a lot what I'm able to do
but I you still need a human in the loop
to kind of manage the design of things
manage like what are the prompts that
generate the kind of stuff to do some
basic adjustment of the codes let's do
some debugging but if it's possible to
add on top of GPT for kind of uh
feedback loop of of uh self-debugging
improving the code and then you launch
that system out into the wild on the
internet because everything is connected
and have it do things have it interact
with humans and then get that feedback
now you have this giant ecosystem yeah
of humans that's one of the things that
uh yeah Elon Musk recently sort of
tweeted as a case why everyone needs to
pay Seven dollars or whatever for
Twitter to make sure they're real
they're make sure they're real we're now
going to be living in a world where the
the Bots are getting smarter and smarter
and smarter to a degree where you can't
uh you can't tell the difference between
a human and a bot that's right and now
you can have uh Bots outnumber humans by
yeah one million to one which is why
he's making the case why you have to pay
yeah to prove you're human which is one
of the only mechanisms which is
depressing and I yeah I feel we have to
remember
as individuals we should from time to
time ask ourselves why are we doing what
we're doing right then as a species we
need to do that too
so if we're building as as you say
machines that are outnumbering us
and more and more outsmarting us and and
replacing us on the job market not just
for the dangerous and and boring tasks
but also for writing poems and doing art
and things that a lot of people find
really meaningful you've got to ask
yourself why why are we doing this
uh we are the answer is moloch is
tricking us into doing it
and it's such a clever trick that even
though we see the trick we still have no
choice but to fall for it right
come also the thing you said about you
using uh
co-pilot AI tools to program faster out
how many times what factor faster would
you say you code now does it go twice as
fast or I don't really
uh because it's such a new tool yeah
it's I don't know if speed is
significantly improved
um but it feels like I'm a year away
from being uh five to ten times faster
so if that's typical for programmers
then uh you're already seeing another
kind of stuff
recursive self-improvement right because
previously uh one like a major
generation of improvement of the codes
would happen on the human r d time scale
and now if that's five times shorter
then it's going to take five times less
time than it otherwise would to develop
the next level of these tools and so on
so this these These are the this is
exactly the sort of beginning of an of
an intelligence explosion they can be
humans in the loop a lot in the early
stages and then eventually humans are
needed less and less and the machines
can more kind of go along but you what
you said there is just an exact example
of these sort of things another thing
which which um
I was kind of lying on my psychiatrist
imagining I'm on a psychiatrist's couch
here saying what are my fears that
people would do with um AI systems
another
so I mentioned three that I had fears
about many years ago that they would do
namely uh teacher the code uh connected
to the internet then teach it to
manipulate humans a fourth one is
building an API
where code can control all the super
powerful thing right that is very
unfortunate because one thing that
systems like gpt4 have going for them is
that they are an Oracle in the sense
that they just answer questions there's
no robot connected to the gpt4 gpt4
can't go and do stock trading based on
its thinking yeah it is not an agent an
intelligent agent is something that
takes in information from the world
processes it
to figure out what action to take based
on its goals that it has and then does
something
back on the world but once you have an
API for example gpd4 Nothing Stops Joe
schmoe and all and a lot of other people
from building real agents
which just keep making calls somewhere
in some inner Loops somewhere to these
powerful Oracle systems
and which makes them themselves much
more powerful that's another kind of um
unfortunate development which I think we
would have been better off uh delaying I
don't want to pick on any particular
companies I think they're all under a
lot of pressure to make money yeah
and um
again the reason we're calling for this
pause is to give them all cover to do
what they know is the right thing to
slow down a little bit at this point but
everything we've talked about
I hope we'll can we'll make it clear to
people watching this you know why
these sort of human level tools can
cause a gradual acceleration you keep
using yesterday's technology to build
tomorrow's technology yeah and when you
do
that over and over again you naturally
get an explosion you know that's the
definition of an explosion in science
right like
if you have
two people
um they fall in love now you have four
people and then they can make more
babies and now you have eight people and
then then you have 16 32 64 Etc that's
we call that a population explosion
where it's just that each
if it's instead free neutrons
in a nuclear reaction that if H1 can
make more than one then you get an
exponential growth in that we call it a
nuclear explosion all explosions are
like that and an intelligence explosion
it's just exactly the same principle
that some quantity some amount of
intelligence can make
more intelligence than that and then
repeat you always get exponentials
what's your intuition why does you
mentioned there's some technical reasons
why it doesn't stop at a certain point
what's your intuition and uh do you have
any intuition why it might stop
it's obviously going to stop when it
bumps up against the laws of physics
there are some things you just can't do
no matter how smart you are right
allegedly
um
laws of physics yeah yeah right Seth
Lloyd wrote a really cool paper on the
physical limits on uh computation for
example if you make it
put too much energy into it and finite
space it'll turn into a black hole you
can't move information around Fashion
the speed of light stuff like that but
uh it's hard to store way more than than
a modest number of bits per atom Etc but
you know those limits are just
astronomically above like 30 orders of
magnitude above where we are now so no
bigger different bigger jump in
intelligence than if you go from uh from
an ant to a human
I think
of course what we want to do is have
have a controlled
thing the nuclear reactor you put
moderators in to make sure exactly it
doesn't blow up out of control right
when we do um
experiments with Biology and cells and
so on you know we also try to make sure
it doesn't get out of control
um
we can do this with ai2 the thing is we
haven't succeeded yet and Morlock is
exactly
doing the opposite just fueling just
egging everybody on faster faster faster
or the other company is going to catch
up with you or the other country is
going to catch up with you
we do this we have to want this stuff we
have and and I don't believe in this
just asking people to look into their
hearts and do the right thing it's
easier for others to say that but like
if if you're in a situation where your
company is going to get
screwed
if you
by other companies that are not stopping
you know you're putting people in a very
hard situation the the right thing to do
is change the whole incentive structure
instead and and this is not an old I I
maybe I should say one more thing about
this because molok has been around as
Humanity's
number one or number two enemy since the
beginning of civilization and we came up
with some really cool counter measures
like first of all already over a hundred
thousand years ago Evolution realized
that it was very unhelpful that people
kept killing each other all the time
yeah so it genetically
gave us compassion
and made it so that it like if you get
two drunk dudes getting into a pointless
bar fight
they might give each other black eyes
but and they have a lot of inhibition
towards towards just killing each other
that's it and similarly if you find a
baby lying on the street when you go out
for your morning jog tomorrow you're
gonna stop and pick it up right even
though maybe it make you late for your
next podcast
so Evolution gave us these genes that
make our own egoistic incentives more
aligned with what's good for the greater
group or part of right and then uh as we
got a bit more sophisticated and
developed language
we invented gossip which is also a
fantastic anti-malark right because now
it it really discourages
Liars Moochers cheaters because it their
own incentive now is not to do this
because word quickly gets around and
then suddenly people aren't going to
invite them to their dinners anymore or
trust them and then when we got still
more sophisticated and bigger societies
you know invented the legal system where
even strangers who didn't couldn't rely
on gossip and and things like this would
treat each other would have an incentive
now those guys in the bar fight even if
they someone is so drunk that he
actually wants to kill the other guy
he also has a little thought on the back
of his head that you know do I really
want to spend the next 10 years
eating like really crappy food in a
small room uh I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna chill out you know so and we
similarly have tried to give these
incentives to our corporations by having
having regulation and all sorts of
oversight so that their incentives are
aligned with the greater good we've
tried really hard
um and um the the big problem that we're
failing now
is not that we haven't tried before but
it's just that the tech is growing much
is developing much faster than the
regulator has been able to keep up right
so
Regulators it's kind of comical the
European Union right now is doing this
AI Act Right which and in the beginning
they had a little opt-out exception that
gpt4 would be completely excluded from
regulation
brilliant idea what's the logic behind
that
some lobbyists pushed successfully for
this so we were actually quite involved
with the future Life Institute
um Mark Bracco Mr ook Anthony Geary and
others you know we're quite involved
with um talking to very educating
various people involved in this process
about
these general purpose AI models coming
and pointing out that they would become
the laughing stock if they didn't put it
in so it the French started pushing for
it it got put in to the draft and it
looked like all was good and then there
was a huge counter push from lobbyists
yeah there were more lobbyists in
Brussels from tech companies and from
oil companies for example and it looked
like it might it's going to maybe get
taken out again
and now gpt4 happened
and I think it's going to stay in but
this just shows you know monologue can
be defeated
but the the challenge we're facing is
that the tech is generally much faster
than what the
policymakers are
and a lot of the policy makers also
don't have a tech background so it's you
know we really need to work hard to
educate them on on how on what's taking
place here
so so we're getting the situation where
the first kind of non so you know I
Define artificial intelligence just as
non-biological intelligence all right
and by that definition
a company a corporation is also an
artificial intelligence because the
corporation isn't it's humans it's the
system
if a CEO decides the CEO of a tobacco
company decides one morning that she or
he doesn't want to sell cigarettes
anymore they'll just put another CEO in
there
it's not enough to align the incentives
of individual people or in align
individual computers incentives to their
owners which is what technically AI
Safety Research is about you also have
to align the incentives of Corporations
with a greater good and some
corporations have gotten so big and so
powerful very quickly and that in many
cases they're lobbyists instead align
The Regulators to what they want rather
than the other way around the classic
regulatory capture right is is the thing
that the Slowdown hopes to achieve is
give enough time to the regulars to
catch up or enough time to the companies
themselves to breathe and understand how
to do AI safety correctly I think both
and but I think that the vision the path
to success I see is first you give a
breather actually to to the people in
these companies their leadership who
wants to do the right thing and they all
have safety teams and so on other
companies give them a chance to
get together with the other companies
and the outside pressure can also help
catalyze that right
and and work out
what is it that's
what are the reasonable uh safety
requirements one should put on future
systems before they get rolled out
there are a lot of people also in
Academia and elsewhere outside of these
companies who can be brought into this
and have a lot of very good ideas
and then um
I think it's very realistic that within
six months
you can get these people coming up so
here's a white paper here's where we all
think it's reasonable
um you know you didn't just because cars
killed a lot of people they didn't ban
cars but they got together a bunch of
people and decided you know in order to
be allowed to sell a car it has to have
a seat belt in them